ang pagsukat ng isang quantum superposition ay kasing random ng pagtapon ng barya ngunit gaano kalayo ang maaari nating dalhin ang
pagkakatulad bago ito masira malalaman natin ngayon sa Qiskit in the
classroom maligayang pagdating sa Qiskit in the Classroom isang video series kung saan ginagawa nating mas madaling maintindihan ang isang pangunahing konsepto na
maaaring maranasan mo sa isang kursong nauugnay sa Quantum Computing ang bawat video ay sinasamahan ng isang interactive na module na naka-link sa
paglalarawan sa ibaba kaya siguraduhing tingnan iyon ngayon pag-uusapan natin ang isa sa mga pangunahing prinsipyo sa puso ng
quantum theory ang superposition sa ating pang-araw-araw na karanasan ang mga bagay ay laging may tiyak na katangian ang kanilang lokasyon laki
hugis kulay lahat ng bagay tungkol sa kanila ay natutukoy at tiyak kahit hindi pa natin bilang tagamasid sinukat ito sa
quantum world ito ay hindi kinakailangang ganoon ang isang quantum object ay maaaring nasa isang bagay na tinatawag na superposition ng
maraming klasikal na pinahintulutang estado na kapag ito ay nasukat ay random na mababago sa isa sa mga
estado ang pagsukat ng isang superposition state ay katulad ng pagtapon ng barya walang paraan na malaman nang maaga kung aling direksyon ito
mapapadpad ang pundamental na indeterminismo na ito ay isang hindi komportableng aspeto ng quantum mechanics na kahit si Einstein ay nagkaroon ng problema
dito siyang kilalang sinabi na ang Diyos ay hindi naglalaro ng dais tungkol sa Randomness na ito ngunit gaya ng makikita natin ang Diyos ay talagang naglalaro ng dais o sa ating
kaso siya ay nagtatapon ng mga barya ngunit higit pa rito ang mga baryang ito ay may bias ang pagsukat ng isang quantum superposition ay maaaring katulad ng
pagtapon ng barya sa ilang paraan ngunit ang superposition mismo ay mas mayaman at mas kumplikado kaysa sa isang klasikal
na probabilistikong estado upang makita ito mag-iisip tayo kung paano gumagana ang isang klasikal na barya at icontrast ito sa ating
quantum coin na tutuklasin natin gamit ang Qiskit sa isang IBM quantum computer una ang isang klasikal na barya ito ay
medyo simple itatapon mo ang barya at mahulog ito alinman sa harapan pataas o harapan pababa na may 50% tsansa ng bawat isa sa prinsipyo maaari nating
kalkulahin kung aling gilid ang mahuhulog ng barya kung nalaman natin ang tiyak na paunang kondisyon ng barya at kung gaano
kalaki ang puwersa at torque na inilapat sa panahon ng pagtapon ngunit sa praktika walang paraan na malaman nang maaga kung aling gilid ang
mahuhulog ng barya iyon ang dahilan kung bakit ginagamit natin ang pagtapon ng barya bilang isang kanoniko na halimbawa ng isang klasikal na probabilistikong estado kung saan ang
resulta ay mahalagang random kung mag-tapon ako ng baryang ito ng isang libong beses at itatala ang bilang ng harapan pataas
at harapan pababa makakakuha ako ng histogram na ganito ang hitsura kaya mayroon tayong mga count sa Y
axis at maaari itong alinman ay harapan pataas o harapan pababa at ang
histogram ay magpapakita na mayroong halos 500 count ng bawat isa hanggang sa ilang
statistical fluctuation maaari tayong lumikha ng katulad na estado gamit ang isang qubit sa ating quantum computer tulad ng pagtapon ng barya ang isang
qubit ay maaari ring masukat sa dalawang posibleng estado zero at isa kung nag-apply tayo ng tinatawag na Hadamard gate sa
qubit ilalagay nito ito sa isang pantay na superposition ng zero at isa narito ang isang
visualization ng circuit na iyon na tinatawag nating circuit diagram dito ang nangungunang wire ay ang
qubit at ang mga operasyon na inilapat sa qubit ay lumalabas bilang mga kahon sa mga wire ang Hadamard gate ay ipinapakita gamit ang kahong ito
na may label na H at ang pagsukat ay ipinapakita gamit ang gray na kahon na may label na may maliit na simbolo ng pagsukat nagpapadala ito
ng pagsukat sa isang klasikal na bit ang wire na ito na may dalawang linya kaya dahil ang qubit ay nasa isang pantay na superposition ng 0 at isa kapag
sinukat natin ito magkakaroon ng 50% tsansa na masukat natin ang zero at 50% na masukat natin ang
isa ipinapahayag natin ang quantum superposition state na ito bilang s = 1 / sqrt
2 ang 0 + 1 / sqrt 2 ang 1 kung saan ang mga kwadrado ng bawat isa sa mga
coefficient na ito na tinatawag din na mga amplitude ay ang mga probabilidad ng pagsukat ng bawat estado kaya sa epekto ang pag-apply ng Hadamard
gate ay ang analogous sa pagtapon ng barya at tulad ng pagtapon natin ng barya ng isang libong beses upang tingnan ang
mga istatistika ng barya na nahuhulog sa harapan pataas o harapan pababa maaari tayong gumawa ng katulad sa Qiskit gamit ang ating quantum coin
gagamitin natin ang isang Qiskit primitive na tinatawag na sampler na uulitin ang circuit nang maraming beses upang ma-sample ang mga istatistika
ng resultang estado sa isang libong sample ng circuit sa itaas mayroon tayong isang bagay na halos magkaparehong
hitsura sa klasikal na coin histogram hanggang sa ilang statistical fluctuation kaya iyon na ba ang quantum
superposition ay mahalagang kapareho ng isang klasikal na probabilistikong estado na katulad ng pagtapon ng barya hindi ganoon ang ito ay magiging
medyo maikling video kung iyon ang kaso upang makita ang ating unang pangunahing pagkakaiba susubukan ko ang isang bagay na bahagyang naiiba sa aking klasikal na barya sa halip
na simpleng hayaan itong mahulog sa mesa na mahuhulog alinman sa harapan pataas o pababa itatapon ko ang barya at huhuliin ito
sa gitna ng hangin sa pagitan ng aking mga palad ngayon ang barya ay hindi harapan pataas o pababa ngunit sa halip ito ay alinman sa harapan kaliwa
o kanan kaya sinasabi sa atin ng lohika na ang dalawa ito ay may 50/50 na probabilidad din ng pagiging
alinman sa harapan kaliwa o kanan upang masukat ang harapan kaliwa o kanan sa ating quantum coin maaari tayong gawin ang ginawa natin sa klasikal
na barya sukatin sa ibang axis ang ating karaniwang mga sukat sa quantum computer ay nasa patayong axis
tulad ng karaniwang pagsukat ng harapan pataas o pababa ng klasikal na barya ngunit maaari rin nating tanungin ang ating quantum coin kung ito ay
harapan kaliwa o kanan tinatawag natin ang dalawang estado na ito sa kahabaan ng x axis bilang plus o minus
para dito ginagamit natin ang Qiskit Primitive na tinatawag na estimator upang masalimuot ang mga bagay nang kaunti sa halip na magbalik ng histogram tulad ng
ginagawa ng sampler ang estimator ay magbibigay sa atin ng tinatawag na expectation value ng anumang observable ng qubit upang
maunawaan ang expectation value na ito sabihin nating makakakuha ka ng isang dolyar sa tuwing ang barya ay mahuhulog sa harapan pataas at mawawalan ka ng isang dolyar kapag ito ay
mahuhulog sa harapan pababa ang expectation value ay kung magkano ang pera na maaari mong asahang kumita sa average sa bawat pagtapon ng barya dahil
pantay-pantay na malamang kang manalo o matalo ng isang dolyar ang expectation value ay magiging zero ang parehong pag-iisip ay maaaring mailapat
sa qubit kapag nahanap natin ang expectation value ng x kapag nag-apply tayo ng x sa plus state makukuha natin
ang value + isa at sa minus state makukuha natin ng minus isa kaya kung mayroon tayong
50/50 na distribusyon makakakuha tayo ng expectation value na zero ngunit hindi ganoon makakakuha tayo ng expectation value na plus isa
ibig sabihin ang barya ay laging sinusukatan na maging plus sa kahabaan ng x-axis iyon ay katulad ng pagtapon ng isang
barya at paghuli nito at ginagarantiyahan na ang ulo ay laging nakaharap sa kanan ito ay dahil ang isang
superposition ay hindi lamang isang probability distribution alalahanin kung paano natin ipinapahayag ang isang quantum
state s ay katumbas ng C 0 * ang estado 0 plus C1
* ang estado 1 kung saan ang bawat isa sa mga coefficient na ito ay komplikado ibig sabihin mayroon silang
parehong tunay at imahinasyon na bahagi kaya nagsasabi sila sa atin ng tungkol sa mga probabilidad ngunit nagtatago rin sila ng isa pang dami na tinatawag na
phase ang ilang coefficient C ay maaaring isulat ganito
kung saan ang C ay katumbas ng magnitude na beses ng phase na ito kung saan ang fi na ito ang
phase ito ay katulad ng phase ng isang alon o ang lokasyon ng mga crest at trough ng isang alon kung ang dalawang alon ay nasa Phase
ng isa't isa upang ang kanilang mga crest at trough ay magtugma pagkatapos ay pinagsama sila upang bumuo ng isang alon na dalawang beses na
kataas tinatawag natin itong constructive interference kung sila ay nasa labas ng phase tulad ng
ganito pagkatapos ay nagsasalungat sila nang mapanira na ganap na nagkakansela sa isa't isa upang makita kung paano maaaring maging sanhi ng
interference ang phase sa ating quantum coin subukan nating mag-apply ng Hadamard nang dalawang beses sa halip na isang beses lamang ngayon nang klasikal
hindi ito magiging anumang kahulugan kung ang pag-apply ng Hadamard ay katumbas ng pagtapon ng barya hindi ka maaaring magtapon ng barya na nagtatatapon na ngunit tingnan natin kung ano ang
mangyayari quantum mechanically kaya nag-apply tayo ng Hadamard nang dalawang beses at sina-sample natin ang resultang estado
kahanga-hanga hindi na tayo mayroon ng 50/50 na probabilidad ang resultang histogram ay nagpapakita na para sa bawat kaso sinukat natin ang
qubit na nasa zero state kaya ang pangalawang Hadamard ay nagbalik ng qubit sa zero state kung saan ito nagsimula ito ay
medyo mahirap makita sa simula ngunit ito ay salamat sa interference ng quantum state ngunit sa halip na
nagsasalungat sa tunay na espasyo tulad ng isang aktwal na alon ang interference ay nangyayari sa abstract na information space ng qubit
ang pangalawang Hadamard gate ay nagdulot ng zero na bahagi ng superposition na mag-interfere nang constructively habang ang one na bahagi ng
superposition ay nagsalungat nang mapanira at nawala tuklasin pa natin ito maaari nating baguhin ang phase gamit ang
isang tinatawag na phase gate kaya ngayon i-apply natin ang isang Hadamard upang lumikha ng superposition mag-apply ng phase shift ng
Pi radians at pagkatapos ay i-apply ang pangalawang Hadamard ngayon mukhang ang ating quantum coin ay laging lalabas sa one
state ang pi phase shift ay nagpalit ng mga bahagi ng superposition state na nasa phase at wala sa phase sa isa't isa
kaya ang huling estado ay isa sa halip na zero ito ay katulad ng pagtapon ng barya at habang ito ay nasa hangin ay nagagawa
ng ilang operasyon na ginagarantiyahan na ito ay laging mahuhulog sa harapan pataas o laging harapan pababa depende sa
operasyon imposible sa klasikal na kaso ngunit hindi sa quantum na kaso ang ating natutunan mula sa mga eksperimentong ito ay
ang bagong kakayahan ng quantum coin ay dahil sa phase nito isang kalidad na mayroon ang isang quantum superposition ngunit ang isang
klasikal na probability distribution ay wala kaya ang karaniwang pagtapon ng barya ay hindi talaga isang magandang pagkakatulad sa isang
superposition dahil hindi nito sinasabi ang anumang bagay tungkol sa phase na ito sa palagay ko ay magagawa nating gumawa ng mas maganda ang isip ko ay gagawa ng isa pa
na eksperimento sa ating barya mayroon akong barya na nakaupo sa mesa na harapan pataas upang gawing harapan pababa maaari kong itaas-baba ito ito ang
computational equivalent ng isang not gate sabihin nating nais nating bumuo ng isang operasyon na kung inilapat nang dalawang beses ay katumbas
ng not gate na ito maaari nating tawagan ang operasyong ito na square root ng not kaya isipin ang ating ginagawa nang pisikal
kapag nag-apply tayo ng not gate ire-rotate natin ito ng 180° halimbawa sa kahabaan ng x-axis kaya kung ire-rotate natin ang barya
ng 90° lamang sa kahabaan ng x-axis bibigyan tayo ng square root ng not kaya nag-apply tayo ng
ating square root ng not at ang barya ay nakaupo lamang sa gilid nito ngayon maaari tayong tanungin kung ito ay harapan pataas o harapan pababa
malinaw na hindi alinman ngunit maaari tayong magdagdag ng hakbang sa proseso ng pagsukat upang pilitin itong maging harapan pataas o harapan pababa ngayon ang
barya ay mahuhulog sa alinman sa harapan pataas o harapan pababa na may pantay na probabilidad muli sa prinsipyo maaari nating hulaan
kung aling direksyon ito mahuhulog ngunit sa praktika ito ay sapat na mahirap hulaan upang gawing mahalagang random kung nais kong
sukatin kung ito ay harapan kaliwa o kanan maaari ko itong squash sa direksyong iyon sa katulad na paraan at muli ay magbibigay sa atin ng isang
50/50 na probabilidad ng kaliwa at kanan ngunit sa dimensyong ito harapan o likod
ang ulo ay nakaharap na pasulong kaya 100% ng oras susukatin natin ito na harapan pasulong kaya habang ang x at z
na mga sukat ay nagbubunga ng random na mga resulta ang Y na sukat ay laging magbubunga ng parehong resulta kung naiisip natin ang
quantum coin flip experiment mula sa nakaraang seksyon ito ay kahawig ng kung paano kumilos ang quantum coin pagkatapos ng
pag-apply ng Hadamard ang qubit ay nasukat na maging alinman sa zero o 1 na may 50/50 na probabilidad sa Z Direction ngunit
lagi ay ang plus state at hindi kailanman ang minus state sa kahabaan ng X iminumungkahi nito na marahil ang barya na nakatayo pa rin sa kanyang
gilid ay isang mas magandang paraan upang mailarawan ang isang superposition state ng isang qubit kaysa sa isang barya na magulo na lumilipad sa hangin
mag-apply tayo ng square root ng not gate sa ating quantum coin sa Qiskit mayroon tayo ng simpleng
circuit na ito pagkatapos gagamitin natin ang estimator upang suriin ang expectation value ng tatlong observable X Y at Z na katulad ng
pag-collapse ng ating barya sa bawat isa sa tatlong dimensyon tulad ng ipinakita ko lang kaya ang mga expectation value ay 0
minus isa at 0 para sa X Y at Z ayon sa pagkakasunod ito ang parehong resulta na
nakuha natin para sa square root ng not rotation na inilapat sa klasikal na barya sa katunayan mayroong tiyak na pagkakatulad sa pagitan ng
barya at ng qubit state ngayon maaari nating mailarawan ang qubit state bilang isang vector na nagtuturo sa direksyon ng ulo
sa barya na normal sa surface ng barya kaya ang harapan pataas o ang zero state
sa quantum coin ay katumbas ng isang vector na nagtuturo nang tuwid pataas ang harapan pababa o isa ay nagtuturo nang tuwid pababa at ang anumang
pantay na superposition ng 0 at isa ay nagtuturo nang pahalang ang phase ng quantum state ang nagtatakda ng eksaktong pahalang
na direksyon kung saan ito nagtuturo halimbawa kung ito ay nagtuturo sa kahabaan ng x axis o sa kahabaan ng Y axis o kahit saan sa
pagitan ang vector na ito ay kilala bilang Bloch vector at ganap at natatanging nagtatakda nito ng quantum state ng isang solong
qubit ngayon maaari na nating muling isipin ang bawat gate na nakita natin sa video na ito bilang isang pag-ikot o isang serye ng mga pag-ikot sa
barya o katumbas sa Bloch Vector ang not gate ay isang pag-ikot ng
180° sa kahabaan ng x axis kapag inilapat sa ating zero state o harapan pataas ito ay nag-flip sa
pababa na estado o isa ang square root ng not ay 90° lamang sa paligid ng parehong x axis simula
mula sa harapan pataas na estado ito ay nagre-rotate nito sa harapan pasulong ang phase gate ay isang pag-ikot ng phi sa kahabaan ng Z axis dahil
ang harapan pataas ay nakahanay sa Z axis hindi ito gumagawa ng anumang bagay sa barya ang Hadamard gate ay medyo mas mahirap sa simula
ay inihambing natin ito sa pagtapon ng barya na ginagawang ikot ang barya nang walang kontrol sa hangin ngunit ang Hadamard ay talagang isang
kontroladong deterministic na pag-ikot ng barya tulad ng lahat ng iba pang gate ang Hadamard ay isinasagawa sa pamamagitan ng pag-ikot ng 90°
sa kahabaan ng Y axis pagkatapos 180° sa kahabaan ng x axis kaya inilapat sa harapan pataas na estado ito ay
nagtatapos sa harapan kanan kaya walang random tungkol sa isang quantum superposition state o alinman sa
mga karaniwang operasyon na ginagawa natin sa qubit ang bawat operasyon ay deterministic at nababaligtad ang tanging
oras na ang Randomness ay pumasok ay kapag nagpasya tayong sukatin ang quantum state kung ang isang quantum state ay nasa isang
superposition ay talagang nasa mata ng nagmamasid gaya ng malamang na naranasan mo ay malaya tayong pumili ng ating
sistema ng coordinate ang X Y at Z ay maaaring magturo sa alinmang tatlong orthogonal na direksyon kaya
kung mayroon tayong superposition ng 0 at isa sa isang sistema ng coordinate maaari tayong mag-define ng bagong sistema ng coordinate o isang bagong tinatawag na
basis kung saan ang estado ay nagtuturo nang dalisay sa plus Z na direksyon at samakatuwid ay hindi nasa superposition state
kaya kapag sinabi natin na ang isang qubit ay nasa super position kailangan din nating tukuyin ang ating sistema ng coordinate o
basis maaari kang lumabas sa module na ito na may impresyon na tinanggal na natin ang lahat ng misteryo mula sa quantum mechanics
pagkatapos ng lahat isa sa tila pinakakakatakut-takot na aspeto ang superposition state ng isang qubit ay talagang simple lamang tulad ng isang
tatlong-dimensyonal na vector ngunit tandaan na ang barya ay analogy pa rin at kahit ang Bloch vector ay
isang tool lamang sa visualization upang makalkula ang mga probabilidad ng mga resulta ng pagsukat hindi natin masasabi kung ano ang tunay na ginagawa ng isang quantum
state bago ito sukatinn dahil ang pagsusuri nito ay nangangailangan ng isang pagsukat pag-uusapan natin ito
na suliranin kung ano ang tunay na kalikasan ng isang quantum state at kung paano ang quantum phenomenon ng entanglement ay makakatulong sa atin na
mailiwanag ito sa isa pang episode ng Qiskit in the Classroom tungkol sa Bell's inequality sa pansamantala kung
nais mong maglaro ng mga quantum coin upang matuto para sa iyong sarili tungkol sa mga superposition state ng isang qubit at kung paano kontrolin
ang mga ito pumunta sa quantum coins module na naka-link sa paglalarawan salamat sa panood at makikita kita sa susunod